so let's uh go bit back in time let's go
back five years and um and maybe try to
remember how google looked back then if
you uh were looking for something um
like the address of the eiffel tower you
probably um just did a keyword query um
eiffel tower address and what you saw
was then basically a list of website
links and you went to one of these
websites to maybe find out this address
or
the closing times or whatever you wanted
to to get
today that looks a bit different and um
the first it starts basically with a
query um maybe you're not doing a
keyword query anymore but now you can
actually do
some more let's say full sentences for
questions some what we call natural
language queries um and um and if you do
that you will actually get uh usually
better for better results um what do i
mean with better results it can be um
that you directly get the answer to
actually your question to your
information you need on the top here the
address of the eiffel tower um and
you're done then you don't need to
actually search further you don't need
to go to another website uh it might
also be that um you see some related
questions some faq and maybe of like a
follow-on question after you found this
address maybe you want to know uh how
much does it cost to go to the eiffel
tower so great you can just jump in
directly here
um on the bottom there's still like then
the list of course of website links
but also there things have changed
um one thing for example is this kind of
preview that we have down here it's not
anymore just say the start of the
website and the first paragraph um but
we try here to show really the
meaningful passage in that case it might
be a bit small here but it's also about
the address of this eiffel tower
in other cases actually not not even
a
passage that is on the website but
really a condensed summary of different
parts of the website so all these things
um kind of changed and there's
there's way more
um
if we want to summarize that maybe a bit
and like what are these main trends what
is like behind these features that we
now saw um
i would probably summarize it like this
there's one big shift towards content
now so it's really becoming more and
more about the texts and uh and less
about let's say web metrics web metadata
less about page rank or what other
people searched but really trying to
leverage what we have and try to judge
how relevant is this text
for this given query
and
and that's i think a big shift in
paradigm
um
in addition um there's of course not
only text data but there is um also
other types of
file formats of media types there's
videos there's maps and all that get
kind of fused with your search query
second big trend that we observe is um
what some people call zero click search
and that's really what um what we had in
this previous example you have a query
and maybe you're looking for a certain
piece of information and you don't need
to go to another website once you see
these first search results that's enough
you're you're satisfied and um there's
estimates that around about two-thirds
of google queries
are actually this type of zero click
search and
and that's of course for the user super
convenient and it's really a short time
to search
a time to result
if you go a bit beyond that if you look
under the hood um you will see that
transformers are really all around and
they're really kind of invading all of
these different
search features and
different areas
subspaces of search
that includes um i'd say the really the
core i would say of information
retrieval and search document retrieval
listing a set of relevant documents
but then also more adjacent
areas like re-ranking question answering
what we will have a look at today
particularly um and then even fields
like auto-suggest summarization
translation and many more
like we'll say areas that you usually
don't uh bring in connection with search
directly uh but are now kind of more and
more getting into into this um this
field or like uh
getting part of it becoming part of it
google is of course one of the um the
kind of frontier there and
it's one of the big innovators behind
transformers um
they did actually the not only the
innovation but they all also brought
them into production and really at
google scale very fast like one year
after the uh the initial
initial research paper that was
published
and they actually had the first queries
running uh live uh
with google queries and
um nayak the vp of search actually said
uh in an article like this was the
biggest leap forward in the past five
years and probably the one of the
biggest one in the whole history of
search so that's really exciting and uh
and
now i want to focus like zoom a bit in
like how are these transformers used and
as we don't have time to cover all of
these areas today uh i will focus on
document retrieval and and question
answering
so for
i think the the use case is probably
pretty clear the user makes a query and
the system returns a set of relevant
documents that's what we want to do
traditionally we can do that
via sparse methods and also something
called keyword-based approaches
algorithms there includes tf-idf bm25
usually the also the algorithms that's
run behind technologies like
elasticsearch
and they have basically they work with
one uh principle they try to match uh
similar strings then we want to match
keywords and um there is a one
fundamental
belief behind it or like principle
behind it which is called back of words
that you treat a document really break
it into separate words
and you don't care about the order it's
just like a random back a random
collection unordered and that's enough
to find matches of an overlap of these
words
that's very fast no it's it's also
pretty lightweight it's very efficient
and actually it works probably better
than than you would uh would think and
surprisingly well uh and that's i think
also why it has been around for such a
long time and it's really the core of
most many search engines out there
we are then afterwards had a i would say
a short period where people try to move
forward and try things like word
embeddings virtu veck glove and so on
and mostly failed i would say um and
that's also i think one reason why in
the industry uh many people were um
unsatisfied but disappointed of machine
learning and uh it was not outperforming
bm25 even though it was promised in some
research papers um and that i think got
quite some frustration
um
but now we have um since i would say one
two years uh another category and really
like a game changer i would say um and
um there are like these transformer
based approaches now
which really go this i would say full
step towards dense retrieval um
and algorithms there include dpr and
sentence transformers we will later
actually have a
bit more look at dpi and how that how
that works in comparison to others
um these dance approaches they really
focus on semantic similarity so not if
there's really like a string overlap it
also works if you have just overlap
overlap of let's say synonyms and these
synonyms don't have to be prepared
manually and maintained by this like
automatically something in these models
um and these models are context aware so
if you have like a sentence like
i'm sitting on a bank and another one
i want to get money from the bank
the work the word bank has a completely
different meaning and even though
there's like a string overlap the
semantic overlap or similarity is
actually quite low
these methods have one fundamental
principle they represent documents as
vectors and um and that's also really
important for let's say the technology
surrounding these models how do we index
how what kind of database are we using
let's now move on to question answering
so document retrieval i think that's you
know the core most people know what
question answering maybe some of you
know it um but for me that's really the
the most exciting piece where
transformers play a role these days and
it's i think one of the key elements for
um getting towards a zero click search
and in question answering i really have
a question coming in we have a document
and then we put it into some reader
models some nlp models and transformer
and this model spits out the answer
um
there are two types now how you can do
that and the most popular one is
extractive question answering and there
are the model kind of searches for spam
for a small string in this document that
that might be the answer in our case
here large city of germany that is uh
somewhere here in this first lines
um however there's also another
direction which is a generative question
answering
where
the model really
generates a new sequence generates the
answer itself and while this is still i
would say in the early days it's super
promising because then you can really
condense information from different
areas of the text
and maybe even do some calculus like
combining different metrics if you want
so to do that
and then kind of
condensing all that in your in the final
answer
why is it so exciting and and powerful
um well it's uh it's really just became
possible in the last i would say one two
years um and it's probably one of the
most universal applications of nlp
because you can not only use it for
search like for these answer boxes on
the top but you can also use it for
other other use cases like um the long
tail of chatbot intents so it cannot
cover usually all all of the chatbot
queries in advance you can model them
all in advance so maybe you can just use
such a qa model for for really the say
the remaining 1000 2000 queries that
users might have
um similar you can use it for
information extraction if you have some
workflows to automate if every invoice
that comes in you want to extract the
the amount you ask here what is what is
the amount that i have to pay you get
the answer and you can use that in
further automation steps
that's really nice
and to give you a small flavor let's
maybe jump to a quick demo
so i hope you can see that
in a bit
so behind the scenes there's haystack
running it's a very simple ui and now we
can ask questions uh on documents about
harry potter so we have here like a
corpus around harry potter indexed
and we can ask stuff like what is the
patronus of harry
and
now we see you can highlight basically
in the text okay it's like a deer
a stag
magical manifestation of good will and
happiness
um we can also ask
our stuff like what is actually patronus
maybe not not everyone here has a
harry potter peak
uh what is uh patronus
um
and then we actually see okay patrons is
this like magical manifestation of good
will and happiness uh partially tangible
positive energy force
and a few other definitions
so i hope you get the idea well it's
like um can kind of enrich your your
search results and give you an quite
fast idea what is what's in your corpus
um for our users who is not harry potter
corporal but can be like from finance or
legal or any other domain where a lot of
information is stored in text
so
that's like round about what you can do
on a very let's say high level with with
transformers with these kind of models
so let's now zoom a bit further in into
one of the typical challenges and
of course there are there are multiple
challenges when moving let's say this
research methods and models to
production
and
and the most common questions that we
get
are kind of listed here does it work for
my domain how can i find the best model
do users really prefer this kind of
search results and a very common one is
like does it work at scale how can i
make that happen
the biggest challenge that we have here
is really the speed of this reader model
that we saw this qa model and that
actually scales linearly with a number
of dogs and that's of course bad like if
you have
millions of documents that's incredibly
slow
the solution is that we have a pipeline
where combined these two things that we
saw previously a retriever and a reader
and this retriever acts kind of as a
fast filter let's imagine we have one
million documents in our document store
here
maybe the retriever identifies the
10 or 50
most promising documents for my search
query
and then
passing those on to the reader and the
reader then only works on those
limited set and and finds the answer
with that well we already almost get a
constant query time because the reader
has a constant
amount of text that it needs to work on
um to give you a rough idea like what
kind of improvement we can get here and
if we have a corpus with around like
100k docs
just using this reader just applying
directly qa will probably take
more than 30 hours um putting in the
retriever here we can get it down to
below a second usually maybe a bit above
okay that's great but we are now fine
with the speed but how can we assure
that we maintain the quality it's like
all now relies on this retriever how can
we make sure that it really gets the
relevant documents here to our reader
model
for that let's have a quick look at
these two type of categories two type of
retrievers that that were briefly
mentioned in the in the beginning of
this talk on the one hand we have sparse
retriever i think it was also covered in
a few other talks here at the conference
um so very quickly you have a text you
break it down to tokens or words and you
represented them as a as a very sparse
vector
of dimension like the vocabulary size
that you have so maybe something like 30
entries here on your vector and only a
few are like one or other values for for
the actual tokens that that are present
in your text
and that's very helpful if you want uh
exact word matches um then it's very
powerful
but there's also this other category on
this dense retrievers um where we
actually pass this text to a model uh
that can be a transformer for example
and then we get uh also a vector out of
off there but a very dense one that's
why it's called dense retriever um
so it means like lower dimensionality
typically like 500 to 1000 uh
dimensions here and they are all
populated or populated with uh with some
micro values
and
these kind of methods work very well
when we want to find semantically most
similar texts
and and don't want to rely just on these
keywords
that's where they really outperform
so let's have a look at one of these
dense retrieval models and architectures
i would say right now there's really one
quite popular one called dance passage
retriever from from facebook
and just to give you a rough idea here
what is the the
architecture in there we have one
transform order here on the query side
and one on the document side
which means when we have a query we pass
that really to that model and get a
certain vector representation
when we have a document we pass it to a
different model and a second transformer
model and that creates this new vector
um when we have this tool we can
calculate the dot product and that gives
us the similarity score for our search
um
they are trained uh jointly together so
they fit to each other um and the reason
i would say the intuition why we have
here two models is really that the query
the text of the query is a very
different nature to the one of a
document documents are very long very
verb verbose different style of language
queries like very short sometimes
missing out words maybe um so that's why
it's kept basically as a side
okay that's uh that's great now we have
these two transformer models so how does
it actually uh why doesn't it make it
slower now again um we saw earlier run
transformers for on all documents it's
very slow uh so how can we do it now
here um as we can shift a lot of that
computation towards the indexing time
and basically run this part here of the
graph the transformer
for the document
on all documents that we have we get a
vector for each document and we put this
vector into our our database
then at query time we just need one
single vector just like a very fast pass
through that model and we can then con
basically calculate
the dot product to all vectors in our
database that's already quite good and
it's fast
um still
you can imagine if the more vectors we
have here in the database the longer the
stop product calculation takes
time like longer it takes
and again we're back to scaling with the
number of documents that we have
so what can we do um there's uh
thankfully one nice nice trick we can do
uh approximate nearest neighbor search
also called a m
and with that we can really get it back
to um to constant time
and um there are a few algorithms that
we don't
can can't cover in the time here today
but hmsw and oil there are fewer there
and they really make
this
constant time with some tree-based
methods or hash-based tricks
okay great so let's have a look like
what does it mean now in numbers so we
said we want to be better than than bm25
that's why we use dpr and we want to be
fast that's we say okay let's use this
approximate approximation so dpr h and
sw
in this chart we see basically a measure
of accuracy the mean average position
here 100 being like perfect um and here
down the number of dogs the more we have
you know
the harder it is to uh how it is to find
the needle in the haystack of course
um
so um
what we see here is uh basically uh the
dpi hsw uh this approximation is a bit
worse than the exact dpr but it's still
way ahead of of bm25
if you're interested in more details
about this benchmark i'll link to also
the website where we have more more of
them
okay so we are in accuracy
terms better so how about speed
speed wise um we have
25 years like queries per second that
you see here um and uh with
elasticsearch and that setup we get
around about 80. um if we use dpi exact
now that would be incredibly slow
1.5 with this approximation we are
somewhere in the middle and the cool
thing is now that we can actually adjust
this approximation and move
like
as we wish basically between
perfect match and very exact to like
more heuristic but then faster
so as i would say one of the key tricks
to to make things work to make things
scale with these dense retrieval models
and also for for extractive qa um
still i get i guess you you see that
there's like
a lot of things involved and also like
it's not only about the models it's also
about then these vector databases that
can do um fast calculations fast
approximations um and
we try with haystack basically to cover
all of that that you don't need to worry
about it don't need to know all these
details you can stick it together and if
you wish you can still kind of fine tune
it so let's have a quick look at
haystack and the
core design principles there
so
as mentioned fully open source check it
out on github and try it out um
it's
written in python
and the focus is really around search
and information extraction
um the
key philosophy that we have is i would
say inspired by lego um where you have
these nice standardized building
blockses that can have different colors
and maybe like slightly different
implementations let's say
but you can stick them together as you
wish to really complex things
and
that's also how we build haystack it's
very modular we have
standardized classes with standardized
interfaces and then below the under the
hood you can choose of different
implementations that fit for a use case
and because we have this interfaces we
can connect them very easily to
pipelines and adjust it basically for
for the use case the domain that we are
in
um yeah it's really end-to-end not just
the models um it's also includes data
acquisition we have like a rest api on
top and what we call quality of life
features so there's a lot of small
things that usually helps and can be
converter functions some helper
functions
a crawler and these kind of things
we also believe that we don't need to
reinvent the wheel there's a lot of
other great open source projects out
there so we also integrate with uh with
many of them especially actually on the
on the database side um uh where
we don't want to reinvent the wheel
so let's have a quick look at these
building blocks what what can you
actually use in haystack um there are
the document stores
where we have a big variety some of the
i would say more well-known traditional
ones sql elastic
but then also many of this vector
focused databases move as wb8 and that
phase
uh we have retrievers different flavors
we have different uh readers these kind
of qa models from from different
frameworks
with generators to generate answers uh
and phi converters to actually get your
files from pdf or docx or whatever into
a into the document store
there's much more we don't have time to
cover all of them but i hope you get an
idea that there are different pieces
different building blocks that you can
put together
um how can you put them together well we
have this uh concept of pipelines and um
and it's really more let's say real-time
pipelines not big batch jobs or anything
um
and there are two ways to define them in
python one is using uh standard
patterns they're not classes so if you
want to do this type of qa
that that you saw on the previous slides
you can just use that existing pipeline
and it's only a few lines of code
if you want to make it more custom you
can also start with an empty pipeline
and then add node by node and kind of
connect them via the inputs by saying
okay for this query and then the next
one input is this dpr retriever that we
that we have here
and then really define custom pipelines
there's also two other ways to think
about it or to
to do them there's yaml's a similar idea
and usually hype for in production when
you want to configure stuff and save
stuff
and in the end under the hood it's uh
it's really direct at graphs and that's
also a way to think it to export
graphics and to manipulate these these
kind of bolts
um very quick overview because um we're
also a bit running out of time
um
what you can do with these pipelines is
then of course more than these simple
sequential pipelines you can do parallel
stuff so you can say okay let's do two
uh use two retrievers and uh and then
show the results
you can also do branching so you can say
depending on the type of query that
comes in maybe it's a keyword query
rooted to a certain path or it's a
question then we may rule through
another part of our pipeline
all of that is on github uh check out
the docs um all the code is there
tutorials are there and if you have any
questions uh reach out on slack
um very quick the outlook what is next
we work on distributing the pipelines
with a framework called ray uh which i
think is really exciting uh we really
believe generative qa is on the rise and
will be the future um we're working on
extending that to many other data types
that you can also ask directly into a
database not only text or into images
and last but not least we believe in
10 years from now most applications will
have a semantic interface a language
interface and
we want to be the semantic layer there
to to translate it actually to the to
the computer system
um yeah
slides will be afterwards um and as
mentioned we're hiring please please
switch out and now very happy to to hear
some questions